Hi! I'm Briana from
freeCodeCamp.
Today we are going to be
talking about Git and GitHub:
how you use them,
when you use them,
and some of the differences
between the two.
To start off,
let's talk about Git.
Git is a
version control software,
which means
while you're coding
you can save each little time
you make a change.
So if you
make a mistake,
you want to
undo something,
or you just want
to look back
and see how
it was before,
you can do
that with Git.
Git is also
open source.
You can find
Git to download
at http://git-scm.com
they also have
great resources
for documentation.
Now let's talk
about GitHub.
You've probably been
on GitHub before
for some
freeCodeCamp things,
noticed it there,
you probably even have an account.
GitHub is a
collaboration website
that interacts with Git
and works with it
on the projects
that you work on
in your
version control.
It's hard to tell
where the line is
between what's Git
and what's GitHub -
that's okay,
you don't have to know.
What you need
to remember is
you'll use GitHub
to interact with Git.
You'll use it
to collaborate
with your peers on projects
using version control.